so i am curious for the two of you
because they saved the show and they've
kept it on for many years do you sort of
feel like when you need to buy something
it's like an automatic i need to go to
amazon
absolutely i feel a great sense of
loyalty to amazon for what they did for
us yeah absolutely
yeah i'm actually sincerely thankful i'm
like i really mean it i really think i i
i i'm mean it too i am sincere and
sincerely uh thankful and i have i mean
it was such a great moment i i tell the
story all the time when when when i was
at the space conference and jeff bezos
picked it up and i was hugger and buzz
aldrin and he didn't want me to hug him
and
we just had all this and so that was
such a massive great experience and to
continue this show that has just been
such a blessing and an honor and i love
so much i i have an enormous amount of
gratitude towards amazon
for doing that
yeah i'm uh the same i what are you
actually allowed to tease people about
season six i know what i'd like to talk
about but i can't so what are you guys
actually allowed to say
we can't talk about amos's death that's
we had it under under lock and key so
you know we gotta keep that one to the
you know
i mean like where we're at coming into
season six um but what do you wanna
tease fans who like wanna you know what
i mean yeah
yeah there's a huge change in speed from
season five to season six and i think
that that's kind of like it's a bit
shocking to see where we come in um and
then the new worlds and kind of new side
storylines too that are really
phenomenally yeah so i mean i think
you're basically you know this is
we've had you know we've had the
westerns we'd had the different form you
know the crime noir and all this but
this you're walking into a war movie
and this is full throttle heads down it
is the climax of the whole six season
arc
i'm curious for uh this is obviously you
go in knowing it's the last season can
you sort of talk about what it was like
getting that last script
and you know uh because i know that i
believe it was like on sundays the cast
gets together or something and reads the
scripts so i'm curious is that where
everyone read it for the first time
together and what was that actually like
for me
um
for my experience i always
uh i always thought that so you know
we've been doing this for about eight
years now um and uh and it's it's kind
of this routine that's been ingrained in
me we go to toronto we put our heads
down we make this season we come back we
start promoting the season it comes out
we go back to toronto
and so i'm still kind of locked into the
routine of it all i know consciously
that is that is our last season but it
just hasn't sunk in yet so even though
we're getting the last episode and even
though we're going down for the last
table reading we have the last day on
set
it just felt like it's part of the
routine it hasn't felt like this is the
ending so
probably i'll be driving down my driving
in my car a couple years from now and
just break down crying
sure the theme of the expanse is hope so
i think we're just all in a bit of
denial hoping that another miracle will
occur
or you just don't want to deal with
those emotions because it's sad
the the fact of the matter is that the
series definitely plant seeds season six
plant seeds for a whole bunch of things
that you know could blossom in different
directions um and you know my my whole
thing is just does jeff you know jeff
bezos does he want to keep watching it
because clearly he's you know a fan um
you know
but uh for both of you making a show
like this um it requires so many moving
pieces and so many people behind the
scenes that you know don't sort of
get credit so i'm curious for both of
you like is there like an unsung hero or
someone you just want to like sort of
thank for their contributions to the to
the show well you know i don't know if
he's
i mean i don't know if he's unsung but i
would say you know
two of you know so i would say jeremy
benning um is one of the mvps of the
expanse and that is our dp our director
of photography
um and you know for what he's done in
creating the look and the feel and the
everything he's brought the expanse to
life visually
and also lou and webb um who is a
supervising producer and he's been he's
kind of like a guardian angel on set and
you know watching over things and uh
and uh and
he's you know one of my favorite people
he's incredibly smart and he's just done
such great work for us
um and i mean i could go on and on you
know uh uh we got uh and also you know
and i mean i know that you we've
interviewed him we've had him on but
naren shankar the show runner you know
the
the reason that we love this show so
much and
the show runner sets the tone and it
sets the the the work ethic and and
inspires and motivates and that's where
the leadership starts and i think we've
had we have the best in the business
wood and rain the reason why the set has
been so harmonious and such a fun and
wonderful place to work and so
creatively supporting is because we've
had naren shankar as the as the
showrunner
is there anyone you want to add
i'll add in
props i mean they had to hear us spit
your moan getting into those suits every
day and those backpacks and fans not
working it's like they did such a great
job and then just i mean hair and makeup
we spend most of our time with these
people and they read the books and
listen to the audiobooks and they would
be involved in these conversations and
the different worlds and they were
really
just genuinely inspired um and like to
converse about it i mean just
and joanne in wardrobe i mean
like
which i am most impressed about is
joanne and all that she keeps up with
all the different looks of all the
different mars and earth and
uh the opa and outer asteroid belts and
all those things her creating these
different looks and visions and
everything
to me i think that's the hardest job on
set
you know like to keep up with all those
different things and so she just does a
really incredible job yeah talented
sweetheart and then
so many everyone on set
what was it like because uh fans really
love the dynamic between your two
characters and i'm curious what was it
like after last season aired uh did you
go online and look at social media at
all and see because it was it was so
well done um and i'm just curious like
if you notice what fans were saying if
you pay attention
i
i try to stay away from
i don't i try not to you know i think uh
a lot of times because i i make a an
effort to not really read anything
online
um just be you know just because you
never know what you're going to read you
might read something that'll ruin your
day so i kind of make an effort to stay
out so sometimes if people mention
something to me hey you know what
they're saying or what this or whatever
i usually have i'm usually surprised
because i because i'm not
reading or not being involved if i see
something with the expanse i kind of i
kind of don't read it because it's such
this beautiful thing for me i think i'd
be sensitive
to it if you know
people um that i've personally engaged
with on my social media sites i mean
it's just been really supportive but
anything outside of that on like blogs
or articles or community
places like i haven't read anything out
there so i i kind of when you did say
that i was like what are they saying
i don't know
listen i i understand according to um
you know youtube on one day i'm the
greatest interviewer ever and on the
next day i should be fired on the spot
so
you just got to take it all with a grain
of salt you know yeah
it's you know um so uh i know wes that
you mentioned last time i spoke to you
that you casually borrow things from set
i believe you said that so going in
knowing it was the last season did you
casually borrow a lot more
yes
yes i love the honesty yeah i stole a
lot
but you know one of the things too is
a lot of us practical reasons okay so
you know like the thing is like i always
go into
toronto in the fall
and then we're always good it always
gets into winter and i'm never prepared
but amos has got such warm jackets
so
and i'm not gonna go i'm not gonna go
shopping i don't like to go shopping for
clothes so i just i just you know just
take that coat home keep me warm you
know that's what i have to do and there
have been moments where we've been out
to dinner and and dom say to me are you
wearing your wardrobe
i'm like i don't have another coat
so uh the answer is yes
i i love it did you take anything
she's honest i took one pair of yoga
pants they're so comfortable i live in
them i still have i have them with me at
this hotel but i sweat in them so much
in those suits that no one would ever
want to wear it after this interview
we're going to get a bill for all the
stuff that we've stolen
i don't think i think they're just uh
um
besides your own storyline i am curious
which one
did you think was just really well
written i mean obviously the entire show
was so well written but like was there
one that really stood out for you
yeah i mean i think what they've done
with drummer's character has been
incredible i think that uh you know the
fact that that she's been an
amalgamation of a lot of other different
characters from the books and they
created them and built this beautiful
art to be one of the fascinating
characters
of the one of the most fascinating
characters of experience i think they've
done a good job with it and where it
ends up at the end of this season is
really powerful and moving on so many
levels in our
political social you know our just the
climate of
gender and political just how
everything's playing out um
really excited for everyone to see it
yeah the the finale is what we call good
um
i wish i could really get into that um
yeah uh what do you think actually like
years from now what do you if if this
ends up being
the end of playing these characters
years from now what do you think will
actually be the thing that you miss the
most
i think the relationships i think that
the
um
we've been together now for eight years
and working with this crew and the cast
and the writers and
um
we've had this you know family-like
camaraderie and i think i'll miss that
the most
the growth
and the like there's just it's fun um
and i think growth is fun even when it's
really challenging i i really
love that so
the passion behind this project of all
of the creators and writers and like we
were talking about all of everyone on
set um
is just a really high caliber project i
could only hope and pray that anything
following would be
somebody close to it
one of the things that i love about the
show one of the many things is that i
like that the proto-molecule is really
not like the mcguffin it's sort of just
like what helps everything get done if
you know what i mean like the writing is
it's not about them like falcon yeah
yeah it's it's not gonna solve like it's
not going to solve anything it just
leads characters searching for power and
whatever else did you sort of talk about
the writing on the series because i just
think it's so well done and and just so
deep
well what i think is unique about uh the
expanse
is that it's a genre fire firing on all
cylinders and i've read really great
genre that was very strong in the sci-fi
and the science and the theoretical
science of it and then uh you read some
but they'd not really as the characters
aren't as well developed it's they're
not as interesting they don't really
move me emotionally and then you read
things that are really moving and
they're great character developments but
the whole sci-fi and the genre side
doesn't really work i think s uh the
expanse fires on all those cylinders i
think it's beautiful moving stories with
characters that you can connect and
relate to when you're and you're
invested in them in their journeys but
it's also the science is
mind-blowing and theoretically
interesting and fascinating and accurate
and
so it's exciting on all levels of
storytelling
very layered
complex
i mean some of the writers they came
from training of like game of thrones
and so it's very much compared to the
how
how many layers of worlds that there are
and that and that's
that's
a whole other thing so i think comparing
it is hard
and then how relevant it is
just what's going on with our world and
how we could possibly see our future
um with wanting to terrify mars or
colonize the galaxy what that could
possibly look like with the way that
humans operate and how we take care of
each other or lack thereof
so you know
having it
make people think
about where we're headed and why and how
we can possibly be better
like that is all ingrained in the
creator's thought process of how they
how they kind of
encapsulate this ending that we're
coming up against and i think it's a
really important narrative and it's
fairly it's an it's a new
ending to these stories from our our
history of
colonization and who wins and what is
right and wrong so i think that it's
it's important to project that into our
future when you said the writers
training like game of thrones i pictured
them all with like big broad swords and
like
fighting and sharpening and like
um i got i got to stop there i'm just
going to say i really want to thank you
guys for uh for making the show it's
been such a blast i love it and thank
you so much